- So Toheeb, your mama's dream
was for you to be the UK's first
Black prime minister, right?
- Yep.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Have you let her down, you feel?
- Disappointed, 100%.
Like, 'cause that was
the route that I was on.
I was like a super academic kid in school
and then like, just for some reason,
just decided to u-turn into acting.
And for her it must have been
insanely surprising though.
'Cause it's like,
suddenly your kid just
might as well have told you
he wants to be a clown
and go to clown school.
And yeah, but, you know,
I went to drama school
and once you know, we started
on our way with acting,
she was insanely supportive.
So my thing was always,
I'm not gonna be the UK's
first Black prime minister
but I might play him in a show one day.
- I know, that's-
I'm so curious.
Like, that's such a cool thing
to be active in as a kid.
Like, what do you think
made you pivot into acting?
- I mean, I had some
really dope teachers, but-
I don't know, I think there's
something about, you know,
like, being a kid with a funny accent.
I came from Nigeria.
And there's something about
performing that is a way to-
You know, you can hide in
your characters, I guess.
And so like that became a
thing where it was like,
I didn't feel so isolated
when I was a part of a company
or, you know, doing plays
or hiding in a character.
And so yeah, that kind
of just became my escape
in a little way.
And then it became the
thing where I was like,
if I am doing law every day
for the rest of my life,
I'm gonna be pretty miserable,
but if I'm doing this thing,
then I might not be that sad.
- Well, I can tell your
mom is super proud.
I'm a mama.
- I hope so.
- Yeah, you're proud anytime
your kid finds themselves.
Or finds themself? Themselves?
How many are in there?
Finds themself and really
loves what they're doing
and is passionate about it.
That's cool.
- You're also making money.
- Yeah, there's that.
I mean, I've moved out,
like you know what I mean?
I can afford to live with myself.
- It's like oh, he can afford to do this.
- My brother and I might be eating bread
and water every day, but-
- Oh my god, I lived on ramen.
I lived on ramen.
- Have you ever tried Indomie?
It's like Nigerian ramen noodles.
- [Kelly] No.
- I'm going to find a way
to grab you some and get you some.
I mean, you probably don't need-
- I love ramen.
- Yeah?
- Yeah, I try everything.
I was very lucky.
So from 19 I ended up traveling
like, all over the world
so I've been to a lot of different places.
So I'll try anything.
I won't love everything, but I'll try it.
- Let me know how you feel.
- Yeah.
- I'm actually gonna, yeah-
That's my mission, I'm
gonna get you some Indomie
- Okay, I like this mission.
I'm willing to do this.
- Do I get some?
(audience laughs)
- [Toheeb] That was a given, man.
- [Kelly] He's gonna bring it to improv.
- [Toheeb[ Everyone I meet gets,
gets Indomie automatically.
- Perfect.